yeah welcome to the video from round
five of the candidates tournament and a
very eventful round maybe the most
interesting to date in this tournament I
could really do a 30 minute video on
almost all the games so they each I mean
and so I need to be briefed on on some
of them even if they are really
interesting I want to concentrate on one
game later this is some Kramnik against
aronian but i want to show on some i
want to show all the games but keep the
notes brief on on these so on let's
start we show great job of a very slow
start here with the Queens gambit
declined this is in fact a variation
which has been discussed at length at
the last candidates tournament in Kazan
2011 was played by more than one player
most of players played this line so very
tedious variation of the Queens gambit
declined like managed to get rid of his
light squared Bishop here by a six and
we see that this all leads to rather
close position Black has got the a file
but he's got a space disadvantage so
black has no chance to get anything
active in this position so after a while
we had an exchange on in five and there
really wasn't happening much and this
really looked like one of those rather
typical games were simply nothing
happens but then suddenly look at this
resolve sacrificed a bishop here
and yeah just for two pawns but it seems
to be quite interesting and leading to
some some decent compensation maybe he
was afraid that if he didn't do that
that the long run his position would get
a little bit too passive well anyway I
mean ideas like rook a2 and of course
pushing the pawns led to this position
where white regroup the night and now
started to get their counter play on the
King side we see that it was a bit of a
shuffling around and now white gets
going with FY this was very important if
he wouldn't have gone for this active
counterplay I think white would have
landed in trouble and the ideas if you
take this way then tapes on d5 and then
it's just too connected as pawns and
they're also counterplay ideas now so
cannot take with the poem and if you
take with the Jeep on then why just got
this idea and this secures the draw yeah
whiter needs to go for the draw he
cannot play forward those pawns are too
dangerous rajala played Queen c2 which
is a bit more testing actually takes
takes and Knight to f4 yeah until the
points are dangerous so white must be
cautious and to what he did is the the
right thing he regrouped the night and
now just gave it back if you try to play
for when you can easily use against
three connected passed pawns and here
draw was the grid after loop de Franchi
five it's just three again three and
nothing happening so I'm some some brief
excitement with the peace sacrifice but
somehow the equilibrium must never
really undisturbed in this game that it
happens sometimes okay
next game I want to look at briefly is
some cards against what black even shock
against Carlton so the co-leader and
what number one with black against the
very unpredictable event shock and we
gather on groove out but we should have
form this is all played really really
really often and here counts in place
I'm surprisingly the move route 28 I had
to look this up I never saw the smooth
but it's a it is a viable line and only
it's really out of fashion and seems to
be somewhat weaker than the the normal
continuation which is the simple captcha
on c4 where this happens and black Yuri
is very close to a quality but maybe he
wanted to post more problems and play
group d 8 he took some time for that
though yeah he won choke took 30 minutes
for Queen 84 yeah he's just just
unbelievable he lost two times already
on time and this tournament and studies
burning burning time magno tomorrow so
he advanced here on the queenside and
got really I think look at this a quite
quite good position I mean why does
great development good pieces he's got
pressure on this pawn and blackest is
really am ready yeah in a box on still
so it should be something for white cars
in defended very well though he's not
work number one and all time yellow
records holder for nothing he's a great
defender
yeah now he gives up this porn but this
should be better for Wyatt in a way even
shook kept some advantage all the way
but I mean it did somehow wasn't that
serious I mean a couple of moves later
we see that to look at the clocks that
he won Sugar's getting low on time again
but he managed to keep his cell his
extra porn and got a couple of exchanges
yeah Carlsen with his pieces protecting
those entry squares and I think there
are some there's some reasoning um to
say that black maybe has got some
compensation for the pond it's not like
something you do deliberately but it
somehow work this way Black has ideas
with rook c8 loop situ or root C for
maybe those poems on b5 and a2 are not
exactly grade so black has a bit of play
for the pawn and we see that now and
then yeah first protecting and kicking
this night back and now king of seven
yeah now we see this this counter play
probably one shook at this point had
chances to improve but it's difficult I
didn't I couldn't really pinpoint an
exact exact move as mentioned he keeps
something all the way but here for
example covers a fall and in fact I'm
around here aventure can offer to draw
but counts declined funny enough with
the porn down but he thought that he
would win back upon and then maybe can
can try something he he very was very
young very critical about this decision
in the press conference I managed to saw
that he was really been angry with
himself that year that he didn't realize
that he's still in danger here okay he
also said that which was quite
interesting that in general he thinks
well the drawers well he shouldn't
accept the draw on general grounds
because the game should be played out um
okay but if you're worse and I in
trouble and you should maybe take it
yeah well he said it himself he should
have taken it okay the thing is he
thought probably that okay you will get
the porn back which is true but probably
should do some waiting movie instead of
capture and he took now immediately and
now there's night before and you could
see it on the webcam that he had
underestimated this move sometimes you
really can see it in the in the body
language and he solved this move Roxy 7
coming before but he did some sort of
miscalculation and now he realized that
could be trouble this is the best
defense really setting up this maneuver
the only good thing here about
l'exposition is of course the king it is
only six and helps with the defense and
tell where this porn is also possible
target right them repeated here and then
exchanged rooks
yeah it's really it's really interesting
this position if firm white um is able
to do something here maybe is I mean in
the press conference I think both
players agree that it is probably a draw
and short who did the on-site comments
and also sati it's pretty sure that it's
a draw and maybe there is something in
the game we had this exchange and now
black with the counter play against the
poem so white try to get something going
quickly on the King said you cannot also
just give away the porn so he attacked
himself with h5 takes and now the King
gets active so like Scott this counter
play now and the active King and this is
the main thing you can basically here
already see the drawing idea black wants
to go with the King here abandoned this
pawn and get away i get get rid of all
the pawns we see this this happening in
the game this night is catching the jeep
on and now like a text the remaining two
points which get liquidator TM and it's
a draw they played this last couple of
moves until everything was gone maybe
there was something even in the end game
but a bit of a hairy game forum for
Carlton he was in trouble right out of
the opening and somehow managed to ya to
wriggle out of this but it was it was a
shaky game he could have easily lost
this I think okay so now a look at swig
law against gal front quite quite a
battle
can say that much this is a funny moment
I think that they play gruene felt with
witla being white and girl from being
blackness simply simply funny because
witless the number one expert and the
regroup food addict for all his life and
Galfar never played the gruel for before
the reimage the World Championship match
last year against aren't we played the
groom for as a surprise weapon and now
he plays plays it again against the
swidler I think they I I didn't at the
time to look it up but probably they
have like 30 games for the games or
something like this played with Dell fun
being widened the Guru frantic gets
witla so we have reversed roles okay
swidler took and played bishop d 2 this
is some an interesting sideline and it
gets even more obscure now night to be 6
this it takes the pawn now the normal
move is just 9 a-3 on moving the bishop
again like Bishop g5 or something he
played III though Bishop g7 and now we
played the really weird move f 4 which
is bit of a bit of a shock if you look
you look at it for the first time why it
sets up something that looks a bit like
stone wall but of course it's an half
open center yeah this is funny enough i
move that actually a computer engines
the proof of um interesting yeah well it
looks really weird to play that way but
it has got its points sula and the press
conference set one of the points was
that it is so weird that she may be a
hope to provoke a bit to do something
something strange because maybe it is
weird looking but it's not so bad okay
castles are certainly all right Knight
f3 and now Bishop g4 and this is a
I think already a bit questionable we
quickly see what happens to black black
position minka font is not really a
group a player who's playing this
opening on a regular basis um and they
both were very critical about this in
the press conference so aged 33 takes c6
and and this was also heavily criticized
by both players now White has a very
simple plan you just played h4 h4 h5
Caitlyn style the problem is what is
black going to do about that the normal
kind of response would be aged five but
this simply is not only can play a fight
with a large advantage or g4 which is
maybe even more powerful white can just
guess along and get an automatic attack
it doesn't even have something
sacrificed for this so you cannot go age
five and this means white will manage to
play h5 himself so 97 h 5 e6 exchanged
and what a position like this got the H
file open he can cast along and this is
simply terrible here there was more than
one good moves Wiggly I played a good
one but he had also easy moves like
longer serves you played the movie for
which is still okay f5 and now here's
the really critical position where I'm
villainous words committed a serious
mistake by simply spending too much time
he played a move which is not bad at all
this is the most g4 very aggressive but
it took him like 30 minutes and he said
just playing a good move in five minutes
would have been very very much more to
the point he could for instance played a
simple move like 'if i have just
shutting this [ __ ] about and continuing
with long castles and g4 this is
just an attack for nothing why it's got
two bishops space advantage the only
thing that black has is this d 5 square
but there's two nights for one square
and so then why it would be a in great
shape Ian what you did was okay it just
took him a bit of time okay 96 and if
you look at this position white white
must be excellent here I'm sorry here
and white also i had a good move d 5 s
what worked with the plate that was also
be should be three this was the game
booth who should be three was also
possible just covering the deep bond
maybe it's will I didn't play it because
he's them yeah no one has a bit of a
bishop our fetishes he doesn't like to
give them away d5 very direct move takes
and grown castles the idea was to
temporarily sacrifice a pawn and get it
back later here on d5 and white is still
in great shape but he loses the threat
in the next couple of moves night to be
five Queen d5 and Queen h3 intending
queen edge that but if you look at the
position yeah we are whites attacking
pieces this is a bit of a problem here
somehow played this some a bit too yeah
let's say a bit too hastily you didn't
really have all his pieces in play and
it's already tricky white is still
better but it's not a clear-cut winner
something group c 8 t 1 and group c 6
this covers the d6 square so that you
can actually sacrifice an exchange here
swidler now played e6 and this is said
this is a mistake it is based on a
concrete line or concrete lines but they
they don't really seem to work out with
the move like
Bishop see one time Roxy one of Bishops
Ahmad Brooks e1 and he could have
continued with exchanging this this rook
and then tried to play 926 this still
would have been quite good for what so
maybe I'm maintaining some advantage
only went with e 6 and okay this has
some ideas of black now take with the
rook for example not see seven it's a
very big frog and this win season so
what words black supposed to do we took
with the Queen not much choice and then
Bishop g2 this was the idea gaining a
tempo but Lex got this fork tweenage
seven king rookie one heads very
tactical and they both with the approach
to really time travel 19 minutes and 13
minutes for really a super complicated
position Queen f6e I now another very
critical moment we see that rook h8 as a
possibility trapping the Queen also what
is attacking the rook all the time this
is also in the position he played to the
capture and 92 c7 and now rook a jade in
fact him delfin odds could have played
94 which would have been quite
interesting maybe it's even even good
for black but here he went Luke h8 and
here switch I played a funny move he
took on age 8 so really interesting he
could have played an another weird move
which probably secures the draw this is
rook each rope to e6 yet counter-attack
against blacks queen and black has not
much of a choice he needs to take here
then you have got rook f6 and now this
rook is also hanging Bishop group and
some king here and back 94 and Kings it
to something like this is probably
around equal and should done maybe end
in the draw he took on h8 though it's a
very funny idea recaptures and night to
e8 and now look at the screen it doesn't
have many squares the thing is
girlfriend has got one minute 50 seconds
on the clock and he can now get an
advantage but this is really hard to do
because you know he's got a very safe
move which is ok but what he could try
as he could instead of this preserve the
Queen with Queen to d8 however after
rook takes h8 this looks really tricky
look at this King 95 is the only move
everything else loses even check and
this position and you need to judge with
my one minute on the clock that this
position is good for black and this is
tricky look at the King it is Sir it is
in trouble I mean there are all kinds of
moves possible and nothing seems to
really work right it's not very well
coordinated but you can easily see
ghosts in this position this is why
Gavin didn't play Queen d8 he just took
this rook and returned material and this
after Knight f6 93 with the intention to
go to you for let her draw yeah girl
hunt offered to draw and villa obviously
also be disgusted that he's bought this
brilliant position out of the opening
accepted the draw it's probably really
around equal I'm still surprised that
the chess engine just gives us a 000 but
ok it's it's it's really around equal
blacks got two points for the exchange
and dumb white will activate yet it's
really Josh but surprising that the
engine gives this a stupid 0 yeah great
fighting game which is really
complicated around here they didn't have
the the time available to do to do a
real deep analysis I pointed out the the
most important junk chest though and
really a shame for swidler that he
didn't manage to win this kind of
position I mean this is so overwhelming
provide and if a player let's say 300
points better than you would offer you
draw you must decline as wide because
it's so so much at what ages that you
cannot cannot take it wrong okay so um I
saw I have one game and this was kramnik
against Aronian I'm need to take em into
account the standings erroneous on + 2
12 games and two draws and chrome Nick
only drew his game so he needs to win a
game and against Aronian would be here
the best way to do it so to say because
you just catch him he would affirm he
would have from over counter the
one-point deficit he's six c4 and c6 so
we have a ready system reti opening
quite a rare guest at this level because
it's not the most forcing line but it's
a it's very interesting so um that
cromley goes for that one ratio we had
the certainly that this kind of opening
so while not being so aggressive
instantly keep pieces on the board and
allow you two to get play later it's not
so often that in those
you get some fourth line which simply
exchanges all pieces and it's a draw
that sometimes happens in more
aggressive looking openings on one
example not of a super aggressive
opening but yesterday we've got the game
aronian with wide against witless
wiggler played some rare lining the
Queens gambit accepted he I had a great
preparation obviously and the boy was
empty after 20 moves and this doesn't
happen in this opening maybe they're
sometimes not so directly aggressive
from options but later it often gets
interesting some castles 9 f6 and now
kramnik plays he takes d5 this is a way
to to fight for an advantage move like
be three assaults or possible but I'm
see txt file is maybe more interesting
one point is that after I takes d5 this
is actually a quite good structure for
white the ideas to play you for later
this sir for example was seen in the
game um cards and against kayaking in
wagons in the top of the tournament
which ended in this very interesting
long end game win and that cars and
managed to do aronia plays differently
he plays on seat xt5 bishop f3 bishop f3
and see takes d5 and this is an
excellent line for black it's very very
very solid he's gone rid of this bishop
he's got yes put this on the bot he's
got a very healthy structure the pawns
are on light squares with the dark
squared bishop and black has excellent
chance to equalise here but let's see
what happens chronic plays d for this
should be seven and now maybe for some
people surprising chronic plays III this
looks rather passive but in fact it's
it's the opposite I mean sometimes those
passive
he moves I actually the more vicious
ones if you would play the seemingly
more active Bishop f4 then black can
easily go Bishop to d6 and exchange the
ships of Bishop g5 how you can even go
back to e7 and let's say what makes a
move I just put something on the board
then then you have further exchanges and
why doesn't want that romney wants a
fight so he plays b3 and simply delays
the opening of the position for somewhat
later here um aronian could have played
various setups he decided on a direct
attack on the queenside queen to be
aight koo koo see one roof c8 32 and now
be fine this is interesting he gains
space on the queenside and tongue this
sir now leads to interesting
complications um from nikki of course
could have played some quiet news but
what he did was certainly the best movie
played eform opening up the position
here of the bishop and this is leading
to interesting technical on
complications a bad move for black now
is this taking on d4 after a takes d5
this diagonal opens up and why does God
do chances to really win this will the
exchange so this is why played before
here why done in fact has interesting
ideas he can try to exchange vows on d5
for example night XD 5s surreal valid
move here takes and takes oh now what is
like supposed to do we can go on yeah
takes takes d6 push-up d6 and now
bishop and queen takes and now at the
end we see that this backfires it's an
interesting idea this is 95 but it's not
really working an idea three the block
diagonal this is the problem but the
idea is very much interesting and we see
Bishop f4 if now Aronian must move the
Queen if he would go to d7 then 95 is
actually winning look here take stakes
and now the night is attacked if it
retreats or moves away then d 6 is
winning the Queen assign the c7 hanging
and it's simply a big disaster like
loses a huge amounts of material so the
Queen being attacked now has only got
this graph going to be 6 and now it
works really nicely night a for
attacking the Queen you cannot go here
of course because of rooks e6 winning a
piece so Queen f5 this is all force and
now he five and now we see from a rather
timid position where not much was
happening look here what wipes manage
now after b5 it's got a forehead and e5
and and now this sir is quite a nice
position for wise all of a sudden night
here and Bishop e3 and now this is a
simple but very dangerous plan note that
all blacks pieces beside the bishop and
you could argue about that also is away
from the King the king is only defended
by three points and the queen is on the
queenside the rooks are here there's no
defense on the kingside so what um has
really legitimate chance is to to drum
up a good King side attack now to be six
taking this annoyed and after the
exchange opening up the iphone so Black
has got some counter play here and in
fact if you look at this position now a
housewife's supposed to protect the a
pond simple answer not at all he simply
gives it away and goes forever so what
must them take the chance here to to
attack on the on the queenside here of
course black must think about this
threat f5 what to do there was one
possibility and certainly the most
obvious move is to play g6 to stop the
f4 f5 move the thing is it doesn't
really stop it White has more than one
idea to get it going anyway one ideas to
play a 5 instantly captures and g4 very
a direct way of playing but black has a
defense here it all works with f4 very
important move if he doesn't do that
he's simply lost we must play this move
the point is after Bishop takes dance
night XD for with this idea could white
doesn't need to take but it's a
detective cost justification and rook
takes black Scott Bishop g5 with the
tempo this and now 97 and this seems to
hold who black I analyzed this for quite
a wallet I was first thinking okay white
must have something on the king but it
seems that simply is not enough white
has got ideas like look here and queen
2g5 on to h6 it is dangerous but it
doesn't lead to have made the most
likely outcome actually is to draw some
sort of Perpetual or repetition still g6
f5 as we saw is dangerous but maybe not
enough
but that's also this move Bishop h3 this
is actually interesting the idea is
still at five and it can get very very
dangerous let's have a look if he grabs
the poem now and 5e takes f and rook
checks at five even takes takes and now
these are huge threats and in fact black
only has caught one move to save and
this is night takes d5 covering amongst
others this square white can now get the
rook back black really Kim can go here
picture page six and Bishop f6 and this
is believe it or not a draw it's
impossible to mate black and it looks
really hairy but um white cannot really
get into blacks position position with
some checks and once you for instance
leave with the Queen to some square and
that's that's a yeah it's it's a very
bad move but just to show the point if
you go there black simply takes here and
now it's got the ton of counter play
Queen takes d4 Bishop b4 and so on this
is really a draw I mean yeah it's
possible so that g6 was a good good
defensive move but of course after do
six white can try all kinds of things i
just showed two of them there's also g4
for example and it's very dangerous
really okay um Aronian grabbed on a tube
just tape the bomb and now grandpa come
Nick came up with with a great plan you
played f5 this is easy black must take
and there was also this threat so you
must take and now be three and this is
really really strong this cuts this
diagonal so now d Fife is really hanging
with this Bishop and
the queen is really cut off now what is
black supposed to do it seems that if
you analyze this with a little bit of
time member on your hands and with the
the typical help of a chess engine that
night to d8 it's a good defense IAM
night to d8 Aronian played something
simular but this also involves some
technical ideas that i basically
impossible for a human to to spot one
line which is not one hundred percent
force but which is too funny to to admit
it let's have a look at this like
attacks the bishop this kind of stuff
so this position it's um it's really
dangerous for black what is he supposed
to do let's say he plays the passive
move just to show him look back on
something then you can if you want
simply drop this back it's also a white
has got two bishops Center and so on so
black needs to do something drastic to
overcome that oops this was the wrong
button I'm sorry ah I'm sorry yeah I
must show it I'm sorry I must show this
variation it was simply too cool ok
let's put put this on the board again we
were here Queenie to rook f5 and the the
move I want to show is Bishop to g5 this
is just just a very cool move the ideas
if white takes which whatever piece both
pieces is the same thing here brooke a
two and now there's no peace coming to
f2 with the bishop on e3 still there was
rook f2 or bishop f2 and now this Queen
takes h2 threatened and white has simply
no way to prevent it it's really really
funny and this is this is the draw
actually it's quite funny ok so back to
the game aronian dropped the back with
the Queen to a five and covering d5 that
way didn't want to allow the bishop to
take very understandable kareena three
and now 98 this was his plan the night
is yeah actually rather logical on da
discovers epsilon and the last night to
e6 and in this position here Kramnik are
probably missed his big chance in the
game I'm actually suspecting there were
some after that even but here it is
probably a really big
one he could have played here Luke takes
the age group takes eh must recapture
and Queen takes f5 and this seems to
need to a decisive attack at least I had
I've tried to to defend this is black
but i didn't manage the big point is if
black plays look f 787 which looks
logical covering here White has got the
very strong movie 6 and this is the
decisive attack a motif what is like I'm
supposed to do here it's really really
difficult the point is if he takes with
the pawn there's Queen h5 now
threatening on the 8th and black has no
way to cover that let's say Queen B 5
this looks like a good move covering
this then white as the brutal we should
be for utilizing this Pena on the
fifth-ranked h7 is saying with mate age
6 Bishop h6 hammering away so it's the
decisive attack if black tries to cover
me8 with the g6 then there's this move
actually with a temple very very very
bad for like let's say queen here to
cover bishop age six and there's this
mate and it's it's it's still it's
unavoidable it's no no way to to prevent
it on loser lose the house the computer
actually gives a frost meteor I just saw
it yeah it's it's over and probably this
was the big chance taking on CH taking
on f5 what he did is an advantage should
snowed out Queen takes d5 simply because
of those two bishops and the deep on
oops right sir going it's not the drunk
and born it's still moving forward ok so
we have some exchanges now
and the wrong end going for count to
play against the b3 porn and um the next
on couple of moves and you could try for
improvements but I didn't find anything
what actually use this Depot on and
black God counter play with the beep on
this is all rather logical I think yeah
g5 this intense counter play with 96 and
f 4 D 5 m if white would have taken here
then there's F form this was blacks plan
and this way getting the pawn on d4 back
under this is a draw if you get even an
extra porn on on the King side is
probably just a draw so one this is the
way to go for wide chronic play defy
which is strongly once he uses porn as a
son as his mate rompiendo centum look
before yeah exchanging works and now we
see that those pawns are really weak but
this is the way a black was able to keep
the defense going he's got this pawn
this is d hope the opening of the hope
and this is the big EDM the night
supposed to help promoting the porn
here it comes the beep on so wyd uses
the dependences or quite logical and
covering yeah here is the 40-year first
move and here obviously chrome neck is
got done this move available which she
didn't play we need to take a look at it
of course the question is can you catch
the night and I think you cannot
actually I did some analysis on this and
I didn't find a way to catch the night
also checked her with an engine of
course and it didn't manage to hook to
capture the night as well so i'm pretty
sure it's not possible and if you cannot
get this piece on then it's probably a
draw with some sort of fortress lecture
stays here with King and two pawns and
widest got no best ball it's very likely
a draw and this is also my chronic
didn't play it in you he saw this
obviously he tried something else he
tried King III the idea is and this is
quite quite funny actually the ideas if
black now would get the new queen he
would play in this way King to be three
trying to cut the night first and then
only then promote his spawn I think this
is actually still a draw on 93 Bishop b2
blacks got this funny resource over here
doesn't matter and this is still the
draw end game that I mentioned and
chronic however Aronian of course if
this move however played something else
and this is probably better even he
played f6 which is quite funny the
interesting question is would you also
have played this if this would have been
on move 40 with the much less time on
the clock aren't the same well have six
the ideas chronic not took if you take
with the the pawn also possible then
there's King F said blocking this pawn
and then you promote this also can lead
to something like this and this is
similar to the to the game actually and
probably just the draw took with the
bishop check take here and King here so
we are suddenly in an opposite color
bishops and camber whites for two weeks
two pawns but the question is can you
win it and I think you cannot Bishop
takes King takes and now this is they
continued for for quite a while but um
kramnik didn't make any progress
fast forward a couple of moves until I'm
chronic plate
this smooth until they played this move
and yeah the ideas of course to support
here the G porn and black initiate
initiates this exchange and here you can
also see the the big problem of this
position it's two pawns they are located
and you've got the wrong bishop so with
black manages to get the King in the
corner you just need to sacrifice the
age for Bishop against the Jeep Hornet
is the wrong colored bishop for the
corner so light colored bishop for a
dark red corner so the H bonus rather
worthless he tried for quite a while
actually but he didn't make any headway
look here this is the problem if white
now plays g6 which she did after a while
here we get this position where black
has taken away all squares for the White
King and there's simply no way to do
make any headway black just plays Bishop
fhg seven till hell freezes over and
gets the drop does nothing to do I think
they they agreed actually no yeah that
we draw now so I think from like I
missed a big chance we've gone with his
attack here now to the agent here rook
CA drugs yet we never this probably
would have led to a great attacking win
and a very important very important
point maybe there's there even was
something afterwards I mean blacks
position looks really suspicious and I
think Aronian did a great defensive job
but maybe it would have been in vain if
at some point Kramnik would have found
something better
I'm not in a position to to say at the
moment I did obviously some analysis on
this game but it's really complicated
also round here and hard to UM hard to
judge with limited time um I feel there
was something but I don't see I don't
see what exactly at which point yeah so
um this means for drawers and still
interesting very interesting chess yeah
the status crow has been maintained
we're still have Carlton and aronian
leading with plus 25 I swidler with plus
one and yeah Kramnik badly needs needs a
win if he wants to somehow yeah keep
keep pace with the two the two leaders
yeah thanks for watching this game this
game is smooth through this video hope
you enjoyed it i'll be back tomorrow
with the round six coverage thanks for
watching bye